[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa a repasar a toda la prensa
internacional por supuesto con rosa
pérez masdéu sino con quién va a ser
rosa bienvenida ya finalizamos esta
semana y abrimos con una noticia
impactante un vídeo verificado por el
'new york times' que muestra soldados
del bando ucraniano matando a los
soldados rusos capturados que tenemos
sobre esto rosa buenos días raúl
exactamente es un vídeo que no vamos a
mostrar aquí porque las imágenes son muy
explícitas pero que ustedes pueden
encontrar en internet y que como decías
así ha sido verificado por el 'new york
times' en las imágenes se ve a cuatro
personas que son identificadas como
cuatro soldados rusos por su
indumentaria y el equipamiento que
llevan que están siendo atacadas en una
emboscada por soldados del bando
ucraniano particularmente se ve como de
estas cuatro personas rusas tres ya
están muertas y yacen sobre el suelo y
por otro lado hay la cuarta persona que
cuando inicia la grabación todavía
parece estar con vida porque se mueve
pero precisamente en el vídeo se oye
como uno de los soldados del lado
ucraniano dice todavía estaba vivo
dispárale otra vez y pues otro de los
agresores le da dos tiros y acaba
falleciendo no está cuarta persona o al
menos deja de moverse pero lo remarcable
precisamente es que este combate no
tiene lugar en el campo de batalla no
sino que pues son unas muertes que
incluso en el marco de la guerra violan
el derecho internacional humanitario
porque estos cuatro soldados rusos están
maniatados ya son pues prisioneros no de
guerra de los ucranianos y no tienen
forma como defenderse no bien
particularmente los ucranianos que
agreden a estos soldados rusos han sido
identificados como de una milicia de
georgia que ella pues estaría
participando del lado de kiev en la
guerra desde 2014 lamentable rojo porque
una guerra siempre trae desgracia y
tragedia de lado y lado porque recuerdos
igual que son soldados al final que
están cumpliendo órdenes de un ejército
y los líderes que son los responsables
digamos
de hacer todo esto pues están felices en
sus casas el mayor no son dependientes
nóvaya gazeta que es en sus operaciones
por las amenazas del kremlin volvió a
publicar rosa una información que no
precisamente tampoco una buena noticia
que publicó pues que el director de esta
publicación
dmitri murátov que recordemos también es
premio nobel de la paz fue atacado en un
tren que partía de moscú con una pintura
de óleo roja y acetona viene esto le
causó daño en los ojos pero de momento
parece que su córnea está intacta sin
embargo lo destacable es que al
principio pues el ataque fue digamos
anónimo por tos por parte de dos
personas que murátov no conocía sin
embargo ayer por la noche fue
reivindicado por parte de un grupo de
telegram que se llama paracaidistas
soyus y en este grupo de telegram se
escribió el siguiente mensaje como
prometimos pronto los veteranos
recordarán a nuestros grandes patriotas
entre comillas de forma irónica
refiriéndose al nóvaya gazeta
que la sangre de nuestros hijos
gloriosos no se derramará en vano
ustedes bastardos vieron como inventaron
la tragedia de lucha y apoyan esta
mentira pero no se dan cuenta como
cortan los cuellos de nuestros chicos
vendremos a por cada uno de ustedes
esperen porque recordemos para
contextualizar el nóvaya gazeta era un
medio independiente ruso que dejó de
publicar precisamente por las amenazas
del kremlin luego de participar con
otros medios de comunicación en una
entrevista en 'la selenski y deje o de
publicar precisamente el 28 de marzo por
miedo a más represalias y como señalan
ellos mismos en esta publicación
excepcional denunciando este ataque
contra su director lo debuta pues salió
a la luz del primer fin de semana de
abrir no ellos tampoco comentaron al
respecto y por supuesto rechazamos todo
ataque a la libertad de prensa
rechazamos categóricamente todo esto que
está pasando contra una medio
comunicación contra una persona en este
caso el director del medio en relación
como lo comentaba rosso a la matanza de
lucha el medio alemán der spiegel
publicó información de la inteligencia
alemana en relación con esta matanza que
salió a la luz
bien pues una vez más pruebas que
rebaten el discurso del kremlin que
niegan haber cometido estos asesinatos
contra civiles y que los atribuye a un
montaje por parte de kiev en este caso
se trata de comunicaciones de radio
localizadas precisamente en las afueras
de kiev donde tuvo lugar esta matanza en
mucha particularmente y que en estas
comunicaciones se oyen pues a soldados
rusos hablando de haber matado una
persona que iba en bicicleta o un
soldado diciendo a otro primero
interroga a los soldados y luego les
dispara bien y tal y como señala der
spiegel distintos analistas señalan que
por el tono de la conversación parece
que no fuera no fueran hechos
excepcionales sino pues un poco el día a
día de los soldados que estaban ocupando
la zona y que pues se enmarcan estas
atrocidades contra civiles en lo que ya
comentamos el otro día no en ésta de
doblegar la resistencia de la población
y precisamente vamos con una historia
sobre ese tema la imagen que le dio la
vuelta al mundo de una mano una persona
ya asesinada una mano de una mujer con
una pintura roja en las uñas la cnn dio
más detalles sobre esto rosa exacto
porque esta imagen que como dice esa
abrió portadas alrededor del mundo
porque sin ser muy explícita pues es muy
impactante manda un mensaje muy claro no
esta imagen con una manicura roja pues
fue identificada esta mano pues como la
mano precisamente de irina feel king a
la reconoció su hija y también pues la
profesora de una clase de estética a la
que irina feel quina de 53 años se había
apuntado su hija pues conoció a la
muerte de su madre desde polonia porque
ella pues se había refugiado ahí desde
el inicio de la guerra phil quina sin
embargo se había quedado para ayudar en
lucha y es phil quina también la persona
que va en bicicleta en un vídeo que
comentamos el otro día que publicó the
link cat que no sé si lo podemos ver a
continuación en la que un tanque pues
dispara una persona en bici y finalmente
se ha acabado haciendo esta composición
de los hechos de todo es la misma
persona rápidamente donde pueden
encontrar los televidentes los ganadores
al wordpress foro pues raúl vía pueden
encontrar en la página web de este
certamen de foto periodismo que este año
ha ganado y amber bracken con una imagen
que se llama camps blog ser residencial
school en referencia a pues los casos de
abusos y asesinatos de menores indígenas
en internados de canadá sobre todo y una
alternadora de católicos no ésta ha sido
la fotografía del año pero también hay
la historia del año salvando bosques con
fuego con los indígenas australianos
bien hay también ganadores por
continentes y es pues todos son unas
fotos muy impactantes con historias
detrás muy interesante es que les
animamos a ver en la página web del
world press photo así es rosa gracias
entonces por toda la información de esta
revista de prensa de hoy viernes vemos
el lunes con más feliz fin de semana
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día